a issue with the dynamic ones it is um
let's step back what is it by dynamic
one there is a guy named Rudolf Steiner
who founded by better the biodynamic one
movement and he had very quirky ideas
about making one but many of these
practices have proved to improve the
sort of the vineyards the health of the
vineyards and that's what really we're
talking about having healthy vines and
help healthy grapes um he was interested
in harvesting in the moonlight he was
interested in cow horns filled with dung
planted in the vineyard so there's some
quirky things that go along with
biodynamic wine um but but basically
we're talking about the health at the
vineyard and if you have a healthy
vineyard you should have a really great
one with organic it's actually a tricky
proposition because in terms of
winemaking you what you're looking at
usually is organic grapes but there's an
entire organic wine making process and
that sometimes why makers will not carry
through so it's that it's the labeling
is a little dicey so I think what we'll
see is wines made from organic grapes
probably not the entire process the ones
that are that are green and that I'm are
not always reliable are the ones that
are made without sulfides and so in
France there's an enormous movement and
there's wine bars that you know just
have these you know great ones green
ones without sulfites those ones aren't
very stable because the sulfides help to
stabilize the wine so um that I think is
where you can get an amazing amazing
wine
without sulfides but boy you have to be
careful in yer